you told my dad like or at the time he
said kimchi Stu because my dad loves
kimchi chicken which is kimchi stew and
he's like when we we go and we eat it do
you regret eating it and he's like no
what the hell does this have to do with
a murder yeah
of course I'm a Postmates
[Music]
um I wanted to know if we could talk
about like I think it could be really
helpful for for our audience um if you
talk about your experience growing up
with a dad that was drinking and kind of
explaining how he was able to overcome
that yeah yeah yeah sure yeah so
um I didn't know but my dad had gone
through a lot of trauma as a kid like
and I you know he never shared anything
most of the Asian parents like their
dads and probably Hispanics can relate
to this too their parents don't really
share like anything right
um so my dad had went through a lot of
stuff he told me this like you know
after we kind of reconciled and
everything right so he said that um
he had like
um did some things in the past like when
he was in Korea that he wasn't proud of
like he robbed people and he hurt people
and stuff you know and apparently from
what he told me like up a person was
killed because of him so he always had
that guilt and he kind of drowned out
his sorrow with alcohol oh wow and I
didn't know that so that must be wild
for him where he got into criminal world
and then his own kids got into the same
yeah that's what he would always say
when he would beat me I I noticed that
he would be like you're never gonna end
up like me you're never gonna like he
would say stuff like that and then I was
just like damn bro what are you talking
about you know like you're gonna you're
not gonna live that life he'll say stuff
like that he would never elaborate on it
exactly well that's wild though because
he must have came here to change his
life and do all that and start fresh and
then his kids end up doing the [__] that
he was doing yeah and it wasn't just one
it was both kids usually there's like a
balance you know One Bad Apple it was
like both of us were rotten bro you know
and um he didn't understand like the
culture like of gang banging but also of
people getting picked on like in in
Korea I guess they didn't really like
they were they would bully each other
but it wasn't like heck like crazy like
getting jumped and stuff like that right
when I was 10 I got jumped by four yeah
you know and I'm like he he just thought
that was so he's like when when I got
jumped I remember vividly he was like
who would jump a kid like who why would
these guys beat you oh they're kids oh
so he didn't even believe you at all I
didn't believe that was a possibility so
he grabbed me I remember he was like
pretty strong grabbed me by my foot like
dragged me in the room and beat the [__]
out of me that was literally like 30 40
minutes prior to me getting beat up
getting jumped so I got jumped and then
I got beat so when you when you got
jumped were there like bruises and stuff
I mean there was like I had like a
little bit of a bloody nose like I had
like some welts on my you know and but I
didn't have my shoes and I had my
backpack so my my my dad was like
where's your backpack and where you know
what I mean like he thought like he just
threw it away yeah he's yeah because I
wasn't doing good in school too you know
I would rip up like homework or like
fold my report card like a thousand
times and make it this way
I'll be real but so he was like this
[__] kid man what's wrong he's dumb
you know what I mean like but in the end
like I have my stuff taken and I would
tell him and he's like wow this kid is
such a manipul that's what my dad would
always say like you're such a
manipulator that like you you have to do
this like you have to go to this like
language oh man and then he just beat my
ass and I would steal I was a straight
like klepto bro like I would steal
everything as a kid you know and and so
he he hated that like he hated people
who lied and he hated people who still
you know so
um but yeah and from that I mean he just
would beat me and it just made me want
to run to the streets all the time like
that's what my homies before they were
my homies they hit me up they're like
you want to hang out I was like hell
yeah I'd rather be like with you guys
than be at home you know so this was
junior high for you or Elementary This
was
um I started kicking at 11 so like and
then but it was like 11 to 12. like
right I would say yeah like 12 did you
go to Garvey or I went to garveying an
idiot that's like the breeding grounds
of Asian gangs bro I went to Garvey for
so many generations yeah crazy yeah
that's wild was he like the kind of
alcoholic that was like drunk every day
but he's a functioning alcoholic which
was crazy so he would like take alcohol
like to work and [__] like that that
dude love drinking Soju like two bottles
like in one like one Gulpin that'll
that's like what he wakes up to he's
like Korean on the outside Chinese on
the inside show bro he speaks Korean too
yeah he speaks fluent Korean people
think he's Korean people think I'm
Korean like they're like you're Korean
I'm like you speak Korean too I
understand it I understand it yeah but
yeah my dad would just I flew into
Mandarin but yeah so he would he would
kind of like do that to not just me but
my mom my my older brother my older
brother was a really good kid though
like he actually didn't get into the
gangs and stuff like he got in when he
was like maybe around 17 like 16 17. oh
later wow what what got him into it I
think it was just a bullying tooth like
it got to a point where people were
bullying him my brother I remember he
would be like really respectful to
people he would like you know I love you
guys and he would have like some friends
but he was always that kid that was just
really nice to people but they took it
for like weakness you know and then they
were jumping him and beating his ass too
and then he was like man [__] like
race-based yeah for sure
and after that he's like I'm just gonna
join the hood like whatever you know for
protection me I was more like just a
knucklehead bro and my my dad you know
it was more like between me and my
father we had a really bad relationship
more than your brother yeah for sure for
sure so then with that you just felt
like you needed to find a family outside
of your own family yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's how I felt you know initially and
then they treated you well too like it's
crazy like in the beginning like my
homies would take me out and do
everything like and just treated me with
a lot of love bro I remember like
sitting in the cars or you know like
hanging out with them like this is my
family like I will die for these people
and that's that that feeling was like so
strong it was crazy what also you said
that you're you're set also had a lot of
actual family members right yeah they
were like mad Brothers within the group
yeah yeah we're talking about this in a
different context
um totally different contest so not
applying but
um the idea of like finding those
surrogate families especially at like a
very very low point in your own personal
you know journey and stuff like that so
like when there's like a broken
household or something that's very very
difficult to like find that even just
some sort of remote acceptance somewhere
else is like a very empowering feeling
stuff like that so I'm assuming you
definitely were experiencing some of
that yeah yeah and I think that's a lot
of people have experienced that where
people who don't live that lifestyle
can't really understand outside looking
and like why would you join a gang you
know but there's a lot of like it's fun
yeah that too like if you're if you're
getting your ass beat at home which I
was or like when my dad split it's I'm
with the depressed mom that doesn't even
leave her room and it's so sad and then
you go to somebody else's house where
the parents are never there and then you
do it it's like a slumber party really
it's like a it's like a real bad version
of a slumber party you have like 10 15
[__] boys in there sometimes girls
you do whatever the [__] you want
sometimes you just do drugs all night
and you go let's go steal a car for no
[__] reason and it's exciting and
stuff and I'm like you know what we if
if we had like skateboarding or
something like white people have extreme
sports right they go surfing and they
that's how they get their aggression out
but they also have their Crews and stuff
skate Crews or whatever they have that
Bond and I'm like maybe if if we have
something like that you know it would it
would have been a little bit different
because you get bored you're a bunch of
the [__] high aggression boys that
get the [__] kicked out of you all the
time and you just like I need to go [__]
some [__] [__] up too I need to feel big
because I'm getting my ass beat all the
time I would feel like that a lot like I
would feel like when I looked at other
people I would have this Envy like
envious heart right I'm like dude
they're so happy and I'm not happy so
that really made me into a monster too
like I'm like why are you guys happy
like they have nothing to do with me but
I'm like why are you guys happy if I'm
not happy and I had I carried that a lot
I think that's what made me kind of
crazy did you know that back then or is
it looking back now you're like looking
looking back I see yeah at that time I
didn't know I just felt raged and I was
just like and I didn't think but now
that I think about it I'm like man it's
really because I just was it was all it
all started from my heart you know I
talk about it in software like why why I
joined the Gang Too is not like people
think that because you're from a bad
neighborhood and there's gangs and drugs
and violence all around you like you're
gonna join a gang right but that's not
necessarily true because if that's the
case people around me all my own like
all my people that aren't like gang
members they should be in a gang as well
right I remember my homie like I grew up
with them we were walking in the
apartments and I was 12 and he was 12
right I had already been put on at this
time and my homie he was like same
background he had an alcoholic father
mom was like you know whatever he was
Taiwanese
um but same [__] same age so walking to
apartments and this this like known guy
at that time drugs was just like weed
meth and so it wasn't like pretty
hardcore like fencing on stuff right so
he had a joint and he's like hey you
guys want to smoke I was 12 years old I
think that kid was like 16 17. and I was
like yeah let's do it I'm down
but my friend he was like What if I get
addicted like that's what he said and
that sounded so absurd to me I was like
bro off of one like puff like what the
hell is wrong with your your [__]
you're a weenie bro oh my God
I'll take it but he but then he no he
keeps going and he's like yeah but like
what if I ruined my life like he started
saying English dude yeah and I'm like
I was not that smart yeah and I was like
they're kind of a downer fool yeah like
straighter
I was kind of like that dude stop being
weird man he's like whatever man and we
just laughed at him yeah well my life
story you guys know it I ended up doing
more hardcore drugs whatever whatever
but this kid he ended up graduating high
school going to Cal Berkeley he works
for Deloitte now top wall you know
accounting firm or whatever what was the
difference like his I could see that I
trusted myself like hella strong and he
didn't trust himself he couldn't say
like accurately whether he was gonna get
hooked or he wasn't so he never even
touched it whereas my dumb ass 12 years
old seeing crackheads around and meth
heads and all that was like I'm not I'm
not I don't have an addictive
personality whoa you understand so in
that point I could tell in my heart I
trusted myself a lot that's why I talked
like we had stupid confidence
that the way that that Pastor had
explained it to you is so applicable to
that game yes yes oh [__] you're right
yo because I was just like yeah I'm down
like oh I'm gonna join the game I'm good
I'm not gonna get shot at I will carry
guns back I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna shoot it I'm just gonna you know
pump fake right yeah right when when
people start busting at you you're like
damn you have to so we everything stems
from for for me was trusting myself like
oh I don't I'm I'm not gonna get
addicted I mean I don't have an
addictive person like bro I did math e
Coke all that stuff you know so same
thing oh my God I said the same thing
yeah so you're right dude it is it is
that confidence of you know best and
you're so stubborn from it and it makes
us stupid yeah because we're we're right
right if a person you guys ever been
around a person who's right all the time
like that you can't get through to them
but we were those people yeah so when
people would say something like man shut
the [__] up like you know yeah but
that's where I realized like oh that's
where I [__] up whereas this kid he
didn't trust himself he was like yeah I
don't know about that and he never
touched it if you don't touch the drugs
get hooked onto the trucks he never
joined a gang he's from the same area
girl he knows all my homies but you know
he just comes out and hangs out with us
time to time eats some food but he has a
way better life than all of us just that
one like part of his heart and it made a
huge difference I was able to see that
so you said um that you had an addictive
personality you never got hooked on
drinking the same way that your dad was
nah that so that part I really hated my
dad and I was like I'm never gonna be
like oh you know but everything else
like we started with weed and like back
then ecstasy was like a big thing you
know so that and then yeah but other
than that I mean I didn't and I liked a
lot of coke buying I was like a cokehead
my buddies got into to smoking crack a
lot during that time yeah that was big
back then too A lot of people won't
admit it but they would call it Coke but
no one was doing lines man that [__] was
hella expensive but everyone was smoking
crack for sure that was a big thing dude
yeah and I lost a lot of friends just
like their minds lost like just locked
up because they want money for crack and
they did the stupidest [__] and it's
like
that I I mean like they think that only
rocks the black community but man it
came to sgv like it was it was first the
weed then the party drugs and the meth
or the weed and the meth yeah and then
and then the crack game
and that was the [__] weird [__] dude
I think um I I have a question about
that when you when you touch the pawn
like your buddy didn't do nothing but
you did right so it's not just being
poor in a [__] up situation there's
something in us that's attracted to like
a group and wanting to feel that love
and whatever while these guys don't need
it what do you think that is
yeah even though his dad was also
alcoholic too right is that does that
beat his ass yeah his dad beat his ass
too but like I said it all comes down to
the Heart Like There's drugs everywhere
but not everyone's a drug addict there's
gangs everywhere not every so it does
come to that that that heart and I don't
know how that comes about but I think he
was able to just kind of naturally have
that fear in him which I think is a good
thing yeah like when you grow up like us
we don't have any fear it's dumb you're
stupid they call it stupid down yeah you
just do whatever you want you know
because you want to be crazy exactly
yeah reputation yeah so it's it's but at
the end of the day I noticed that like
the people who don't trust themselves
versus the people who super trust
themselves like the ones I trust
themselves that follow their gut they're
they have such a more like stressful
like miserable life compared to people
who are just like okay I'm gonna run the
hamster wheel like this is how life is
and you know they follow like the
guidance of other people you understand
whereas we're like no we're gonna do
whatever we want and it was just bad
damn so at the time that you um that
your dad finally and you guys kind of
hashed it out and he decided to stop
drinking um how did he even do that how
did he say so what happened was he
noticed that I stopped carrying her so I
would always carry a gun just like as an
ex like it was like putting on shoes bro
I was like oh yeah socks but whatever
and then strap you know but my and then
my dad would hate that he was like why
do you do that why do you do that you
know even when I was coming home like I
was still on parole but I was like oh
I'm had that mentality like what if
somebody tries to get me somebody tries
to make their name for themselves right
so my dad noticed but after about like a
year and a half two years I started
going to church and doing all this stuff
he noticed that I stopped like drinking
I stopped like you know doing the drugs
and carrying guns and he just thought it
was weird like he was just like what the
hell is wrong this is not you yeah was
he like are you soft now or what
he starts monkey yeah
[Laughter]
you better you better
yeah he um so he goes to he goes to my
mom and he goes is Johnny doing
something like is he doing drugs or
something that's like mellowing him out
and I'm like what the hell like he
doesn't because we don't really like
talk like that oh yeah because I haven't
really like I went to the church but I
was still kind of like not fully
full-fledged right so then he goes to my
mommy to ask my mom and my mom just goes
well he's been going to church right
like really trying you know to like live
better and this dude
he goes to
um my pastor the same guy who laced me
up right and then he asks him like
somehow they have a conversation and my
pastor just starts busting open like
Bible verses right and he hit on
something about that murder basically
like what my dad did oh she's good
because pastor's good man you know I
showed him this um this verse and I
remember it was Romans chapter 7 verse
17. it says like it is no longer I who
do it but the sin that dwells in me so
there's a basically he's saying that you
didn't want to kill that person so he
made that example like let's say you
guys go and you eat steak right he told
my dad like or at the time he said
kimchi Stu because my dad loves kimchi
chicken which is kimchi Stu and he's
like when we we go and we eat it do you
regret eating it and he's like no what
the hell does this have to do with a
murderer
of course I would love some stupid I'm
gonna post myself
so he goes
um because you wanted to do that you
didn't you don't regret it but why is it
that when you did those things that you
thought you wanted to beat him up you
wanted to hurt him and then when he died
why did you regret it it's because you
didn't want to do it and then that just
like opened my my dad's mind you know
and he was like what the hell like
that's why you regret things that you do
so it's not you there's a force that's
dragging and my dad he'd like to work
out a lot so he said you know you're
you're like a like a strong person right
but let's say there's four bodybuilders
if they lift you up like and take you
away it's like you they can take you by
your will it's it's stronger than you
basically right so this Force inside of
us it's really strong right so he told
my dad you don't want to be depressed
why are you depressed it's because the
depression is stronger than you right
you don't want to feel bad you don't
want to be regretful but it's stronger
than you that comes from sin and he
started to explain it to my dad the same
way he explained it to me and my dad was
like oh [__] and then in the end he
talks about Jesus but my dad was like I
don't want to hear about Jesus as a
white guy he's like he's not why he's
Jewish technically you know yeah yeah
he's messing with him you know and but
he breaks it down to my dad and he
straight up explains him that you know
actually you're perfect but your
thoughts they keep telling you you're
not they keep coming to you then you
explained it to my dad too so when you
lay up in your bed at night when your
kids are asleep and you know everything
else like your wife is asleep do you
ever have thoughts that come to you and
he's like yeah it's like it always
starts like this a really small thought
oh you're inadequate oh you're lonely
and then it starts to snowball you're
lonely you're dumb what's what's mad and
then he says random flashbacks come you
start to regret stuff right and then my
dad was like shocked because he thought
he was the only one that went through
that yeah but yeah articulate that thing
yeah that's what you did with you yeah
and he was like so you like like he's he
used his arm for example he said let's
say your arm comes out and it grabs the
water and you pull it back that's your
arm but if it comes and you're just
doing this and it's you're like you're
trying to stop it it's no longer your
arm or someone behind you is pushing
your arm and you have no control it's
not yours he said likewise when you have
thoughts if they're your thoughts and
you're like okay I'm not I'm done
thinking negative [__] I'm done then
right then and there [__] your thoughts
should stop but if something
continuously keeps going it's no longer
your thoughts do you understand like if
it keeps coming to you it's not you he
started explaining the spirit like evil
spirit and and my dad was just like this
totally makes sense whereas everyone
else he always thought church was like
brainwashing people yeah making them you
know like you know take their money and
this and that but he was able to see
that the pastor knew him just like he
knew me without even knowing him
basically wow and that's why my dad was
like there's something different about
this like bible stuff you know he grew
up in Korea Korea is like really
Christian actually it's overall a
Christian country but my dad hated them
he would throw like bottles at the
churches and stuff it was he hated
people like he said you guys are dumb
and but then he started to he comes to
church now that's awesome yeah and he's
just like man it's it's just different
you know like his heart is different and
so the pastor told him how do you quit
drinking you know like you have to the
thought will come that you you want to
drink but you don't have to follow that
thought you know so he explained to him
when you're out in Korea there's vendors
how the hot dog you know they like
saying stuff right do you hear hot dog
and you just run and spend all your
money and buy it no you think about it
when's the last time I had a hot dog oh
that's right no you know what I had one
last week I'm good this time and based
off of the thinking you make a decision
likewise thoughts come right hey you
want to drink and they make you even
feel like you want to drink but he said
you don't have to follow that you can
actually sit back and realize that
that's not your thought there's an evil
thing that's making you do it because
when you drink what happens your wife is
miserable your sons are miserable you're
miserable so my dad started to he
started to give him like that braking
system and then my dad like slowly but
surely he started cutting down wow
some people just need the tools to the
structure right exactly that's what I'm
saying it's all about the thing like
deep thinking and overthinking is
different we mix the two oh I'm I'm I
think deeply no you're overthinking my
dad with most people are overthinkers
right they think deep no they don't
think deep I'm sure you can like relate
to this but if you felt disrespected in
the past you couldn't let that go and
you needed to hurt them huh
like that was so hard for me like and I
felt like such a [__] if I didn't do
anything yeah bro and if and if I just
I'm like my reputation and all that if I
don't hit him at least
I feel like such a [__] but then now
I'm like
I don't care yeah
what's the point but back then I feel
like everybody that's
in that world where you got bullied it
all starts at bullying you get beat up
as a kid from whoever because they want
to take your shoes or whatever and then
later you're still thinking about you're
like 17 and you're thinking about that
10 year old that bullied you and then
all the Revenge you're taking it out on
these random guys that disrespected you
a little bit maybe they did they maybe
just look in your eye you know and I
remember just lashing out yeah that's so
crazy and you still remember the the
first bullies yes and then that's the
that's the overthinking that you're
talking about you just I'm not gonna let
them disrespect me yeah that's crazy
yeah yeah I mean I I would I would be
like that too bro like anyone who looked
at me a certain way I couldn't even
handle it like it was so crazy if you
think about they're just looking at you
like we had mentioned it earlier like
who are those guys we're like oh [__]
we're eating our freaking JJ Cafe yeah
yeah
but it was it it like he said a Bart
said it that pts it just pops out of you
yeah but I also have that even till this
day they're well you've been in a deeper
like you've been like I had a lot a lot
of years to get away from that but I
still have it like I just don't even
like going clubbing or anything I just
feel like shit's gonna pop off it's
never gone completely but yeah even if
it's like five percent or one percent
there's just still like like I see
people just they're able to drink and
just like lose control or whatever not
at a party no no in a public space I
have to be sharp a little bit no matter
what you know when there's drinking and
it's night yeah I'm like that's where
Anthony comes out
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
foreign